I will take just a few seconds because
we don't have longer we myself and
Stefan will formulate recommend
out of this conference many things have
shown through clearly in what has been
said working together coordinating our
efforts working differently maybe and
more intelligently and looking for
better better models i was particularly
taken by the the ideas of casula and and
Rosie about how to get public awareness
to this in a different way how to use
modern techniques and maybe media savvy
presentations to attract attention to
this course and what I was simply asked
now is I will be willing to share my
email address and you can either put
recommendations for this conference on
the on the Twitter there on a hashtag
culture in crisis or if you would prefer
then please email them and i can give
you my email address or i'll put it up
right at the end of the other conference
of those who don't have it will give you
my card and i'm now going to just hand
over to two-step ensign and two
Thank You Vernon and I promise not to
take more than three to five minutes
that we fit into the final minutes and
thank you Hemant for actually leaving
that space of the panel discussion i
actually had impression at the end if
you would just continue for another hour
would get another dozen wonderful ideas
how and in which direction we should
actually go forward with this I I just
have a few points noted over the day I
think what became clear to me is that
involving the local community but
involving the community to identify
actually the stakeholders of the
cultural heritage and work with them is
a key priority and we should be aware
that that is a key priority on long-term
that is not something which works on
short-term just in accordance with what
the director-general of unesco was just
calling this week we should continue to
speak out against this horrific war
crime against cultural heritage on all
channels as Miss Bokova was saying one
of them is the unite for heritage
campaign on social media I mean which we
should keep that in mind we should
definitely ask academia and museums
increase our collaboration with NGOs I
choose we have heard some of them today
the big question is actually who
coordinates this efforts somebody must
be there to coordinate these efforts a
natural-born coordinator would be in a
UNESCO definitely how can we help UNESCO
to grow into this role a point which
resonates very well with what I have
heard this day several times is in fact
how can we put pressure on those who
support actually terrorism and looting
how we can make this a political
priority how we can even enforce
existing legislation to be implemented
and of course you know not mentioning
the recent security council resolution
21 and 99 this all also in support of
our colleagues on the ground and I'm
coming to my thanks the colleagues on
the ground in the affected countries I
would like to thank all colleagues who
helped us to shape this conference to
what it eventually became
several of them we can't even mention
because they're taking very high risks
to work with us and to support us in
this and of course that comes you know
with the conclusions and recommendations
that I think in our next step we should
try to go with our conference into the
region into the region to be closer to
the to the people who actually are
responsible and to deal with these
problems a point of course very person
from Yale University academia education
came up very often educational training
whether in response to authentication
education is truly key and beyond the
cultural heritage Community definitely
involves the last cools the business
schools we should study I think there
was a recommendation of the Paris
meeting in December we should study the
phenomena of cultural cleansing at
greater depths we should be aware that
this is not something to be dealt with
in a short term I think we're in here
for a very long-term battle which will
last years if not our lifetime so I
would like to thank you all for your
very thoughtful contributions for coming
joining us here for engaging in this
discussion and especially my colleagues
at the DNA Martin long-standing friend
Vernon Mattie and the whole team to host
this event in this in the heart of this
wonderful museum thank you very much
cabron when we started this morning I
didn't expect that you are still in the
lecture theatre at that time of the day
thank you for this very focused great
intense discussion and information was
really kind of totally saw that we had
today and I really appreciate I
appreciate that you claim come and came
a long way to talk to us thank you to
all the speakers thank you to the
panelists thank you to the Yale
University to Stefan for that as you
said long longstanding friendship and
cooperation I guarantee I promise it's
easier said than done that this is not I
mean there will be a second step this is
just the beginning I learned today that
it's all about communication but anyhow
I think communication is not all we have
to talk to other institutions other
networks in the same field there are
more conferences like this and i also
think we have to talk to other members
of other institutions of our societies
and out in an international scale again
thank you for being here today and i
hope to see you soon again
you